- Bonjour. Bonjour les amis,
tous ceux qui sont ici...
- Un semblant de normalité
pour cette Ukrainienne habituée
à enseigner à plus de 2000 km
de la Côte d'Azur.OVOVOVOVOVOVOs
Université nationale de Kiev
- Je travaille à la Chaire des
langues étrangères à l'Institut
de relations i d d d d d d d d ,
le 24 février,e e e est partie
de Kiev avec sa fille pour
se déplacer de ville en ville
- On ne pouvait pas trouver
du calme. mememe quand nous
sommes arrivées, finalement,
près de Lviv, même là, donc,
- Elles ont quitté l'Ukraine
La professeure est venue
ici pa
qu'elle connaissait lui
a proposé de donner des cours
béné
réfugiés.
- C'était un grand soulagement,
oui, pour moi parce que partir
vers l'inconnu, c'est un e e e s
environ cea a a a se passer,
c'est une autre chose.lalalalale
ninininit un logement.
Tanya réside avec sa fillette .
Elle s'émerveille encorededededé
avec cuisine, des draps propres.
"Un miracle", dit-elle
Nice et la France toute entière
ouvrent grand leur coeur
et leurs bras aux Ukrainiens.
Diverses infrastructures sont
Des milliers d'autorisations
provisoires de séjour sont
octroyées, des milliers
VÉRONIQUE BORRÉ, dir. sécurité
san., enviro., risques, Nice
- On leur donne des vêtements,
on donne des produits
de première néces
leur trouve un hôtel et
puis ensuite, on met en place
un accompagnement sur le plus
long temps. On regarde
si jamais ils ont beso
de voir un médecin, un suivi
avec un psychologue, s'ils
désirent apprendre le français,
s'ils cherchent un travail.
- 40 % des Uququququququi
transitent par la route
passent par les Alpes-Maritimes,
selon les autorités du
département. La remarquable
solidarité à leu
est largement saluée, alors
que celle manifestée envers
d'autres arrivants ne suscite
pas toujours le même engouement.
À une heure et demie de Nice,
Cédric Herrou offre chez lui
nenenenenenene heure et demie d,
des activités et un toit à
des gens en grande précarité
sociale ou légale.
♪ ♪ ♪
Il avait connu des déboires
judiciaires après avoir
transporté, depuis l'Italie
frontalière, quelque
200 migrants venus notamment du
Soudan et de l'Érythrée en 2016.
CÉDR
agriculteur militant
- Je me suis déjà fait arrêter
avec des personnes qui fuyaient
également la guerre.
- Il a été condamné avant
d'être définitivement acquittéc,
de multiples gardes à vue,
de perquisitions.
- J'étais devenu l'ennemi
public numéro un en France
parce que j'aidais des gens.
Et là, d'un coup, du jour
au lendemain, même les partis
d'extrême droite disent : "Oui,
il faut les accueillir ces gens
qui vivent la guerre." E
voit, en fait, que si on arrive,
si on a envie d'arriver à faire
les choses, encadrer
on y arrive.
- Son association, Emmaus Roya,
a récemment manifesté devant
cette gare oùssssssss
réguliers traquent les sans-
papiers. Elle réclame un accueil
universel et inconditionnel
des exilés
- Autant garder tous
ces services qu'on a gardés
ouverts pour les personnes
en migration qui vivent g g g g,
les Ukrainiens, de garder
ces structures en place pour
accueillir les autres gens.
- L'an dernier,
plus de 20 000 migrants
auraient été refoulés
des Alpes-Maritimes vers
l'Italie, leur point d'entrée
en Europe.
(chants ukrainiens)
Des dizaines de milliers de
personnes qui ont fui l'Ukraine
sont arrivées en France.e,e,e,es
et la proximité de cette guerre
sont évoquées pour expliquerana.
Et il y a plus, selon
cette philosophe qui préside
une association vouée à
l'intégration de réfugiés
et de demandeurs d'asile
de tous horizons.
AYYAM SUREAU, philosophe, fond.
Association Pierre Claver, Paris
- De tendre la main à quelqu'
c'est faire un acte politique
de soutien et de dénonciation.
Et je pense qu'il y a ça aussi,
c'est-à-dire que les Français,
en accueillant chez eux,
de cette manière irr
déraisonnable quasiment,
voyez, les femmes et les enfants
ukrainiens, c'était une manière
de soutenir leur résistance.
♪ La musique ♪
- Trouver, loin des siens,
un peu de réconfort
en s'occupant.
- C'est une joie aussi parce
que je vois ces personnes-là
qui commencent à sourire,
qui commencent aussi à retrouver
leur propre ca
♪ ♪ ♪
Ici Anyck Béraud,
Radio-Canada, dan